hey guys it is the 6th of July today my
name is Jess and you're watching a news
show about video games celebrate red
have confirmed that a game of the Year
Edition for The Witcher 3 is on its way
Game Director Konrad to moshkovich told
games but with all the free dlc and
updates the game received so far
including significant changes to the
game's interface and mechanics many
gamers have asked us if we're working on
some sort of a game with the year
edition I'm happy to confirm yes plans
are in motion to release such an edition
will release more details including the
release date in the future in the
meantime I'd like to thank every fan of
the game for their support you're really
amazing
the witch's game of the year edition was
rated by a German classification board
earlier today before the official
confirmation rolls in instead of pre-act
it appears to be on its way to PC ps4
and Xbox one now this one is going to
take a little imagination on your part
but Sony has certified a me Bluetooth
adapter with the FCC the wireless
adapter may well be for use with a new
Playstation 4 peripheral the old Jacques
dug up the submission to the Federal
Communications Commission which shows a
picture of the device and it's euh
product code which is associated with
the ps4 and it's accessories the adapter
has a 5 volt power supply and is
described as a Bluetooth transceiver
it's been speculated that the device
could allow the ps4 still shop for
controllers to be used on PCs and other
devices currently there are third-party
devices which can facilitate this but no
official adapter from Sony at this point
though that one is just a theory
finally Red Dead Redemption sales are
skyrocketing and nervous isn't a story
from 2010 since the announcement that
the game would be playable on Xbox one
through backwards compatibility this
Friday Amazon failed rankings of Red
Dead Redemption Game of the Year Edition
on 360 up more than 30,000 stunts which
is an insane increase for anything in
the world anywhere ever
in fact Amazon's Movers & Shakers page
which tracks sales rankings lists a
30,000 3
a 16% rise for game of the Year Edition
and it's currently the six the most
popular video game on the site having
come up from number 1825 the Red Dead
digital card has also jumped 11 thousand
nine hundred and forty two percent in
the Amazon rankings at the time of
writing let me know if you're one of the
many who picked it up be sure to head to
game start for news on more free EA
access games and a possible evolve
announcement I will be back with more
news tomorrow